[Musique]
il y avait quelque chose en premier de
vous des ans le vieux ensemble en même
temps exactement en même temps pareil
nous marchions nous parlions de tout
autre chose on parlait de construction
monsieur chimène et entrepreneur de
maçonnerie
il était en train de construire nos
garages de camions et j'ai tendre à lui
parlé de béton armé par conséquent notre
esprit n'était pas du tout tourner vers
des choses mystérieuses ou cachés et
vers des objets insolites ou rld
on ne peut pas parler d'hallucinations
d'après certains on arrive à voir ce que
l'on veut voir
or ce que nous voulions voir à ce moment
c'était voir monter ces regards dans les
meilleures conditions économiques et de
solidité au temps conséquence c'est de
cela que nous entretenions mignon de
manger et nous venions de rentiers là et
nous nous dirigions vers notre travail
lorsque tout à coup double en la tête à
peu près en même temps et en même temps
une double exclamations mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cela qu'est ce que c'est
que cela la première chose que j'ai dite
à chimène j'ai l'impression que c'est
une tornade qui a emporté une meule de
paille puisque à l'époque il y avait les
moissons une meule de paille se trouvant
dans les champs et chimène me dis mais
qu'est ce qui lie à planter de danger 10
à hauteur des fourches et nous avons
aperçu en même temps et nous l'avons
fait observer l'un à l'autre qu'il y
avait des sortes de tentacules qui
pendait qui remuent est une autre chose
qui a attiré notre attention c'était des
papiers et notamment des sacs vides
comme monsieur chimène avaient des
positions chantier des sacs vides de
papier qui avait contenu du ciment et
qui vole t derrière avec des débris de
toutes sortes qui suivent l objet qui le
suivait de loin comme aspiré par lui et
qui a sensiblement voletant tombé au sol
jeudi à 6h iman textuellement si les
papiers tombe cette espèce de truc va
bien aussi se casser la gueule et on ira
voir ce que c'est les papiers sont
tombés l'objet rester en l'air il
basculait sur lui-même partait dans une
direction dans l'autre direction faisait
des petits tours au dessus et j'étais
absolument hypnotisé par cet objet
insolite
lorsque chimène ne prend pas moins de
gens regardent ce qui vient là bas
nous avons regardé alors là franchement
nous avons eu peur l'un et l'autre mais
vraiment peur car les trois objets qui
apparaît c'est à l'horizon provenant de
la même direction et se précipitant avec
une vitesse extraordinaire sur le
premier engin qui était au dessus
ces trois objets était en tout point
semblable au premier
ils sont venus à peu près opinion dans
laxe du pignon oui c'est cela
voilà dans laxe du plaignant de gauche
les trois et on aurait dit que le plus
gros qui nous paraissait le plus gros il
plaisante même dimension on au risque
qui les amuse et il s'amuse ans alors
des mouvements symétrique verticales
horizontales verticales horizontales ça
vous voyez c'est ce n'est plus le
l'aviation et des malentendus et la peau
car avec tout ça là une vitesse
fantastique l'avion à réaction a rien à
voir avec
vas-y que je te pousse et les trois
objets qui venait on ne peut pas dire
non plus qu'il était en vol deux groupes
mais toutefois il suivait très
exactement la même direction et ou tout
au moins une direction parallèle il nous
a semblé en les voyant venir qu'ils
allaient s'aplatir contre le premier
objet qui nous paraissait le plus gros
et qui était le premier apparu lorsqu'au
moment précis où il semblait que tout
allait s'effondrer au milieu d'un choc
effroyable le premier objet monter en
altitude c'est la première fois que
l'ump n'est ce pas il est monté avec une
vitesse extraordinaire j'estime à plus
de deux milles à l'heure et les trois
autres objets qui venait d'arriver
de la verticale à la verticale et les
trois autres objets qui venait d'arriver
à sa poursuite
puis le premier objet est redescendu les
autres semblé jouer avec lui
au bout d'un moment on n'a plus vu qu'un
seul petit point noir et j'ai dit à
chimène cette fois ça y est le spectacle
est terminé mais pas du tout ce petit
point noir qui était minuscule dans le
ciel bleu a grossi tout à coup il a
enflé enflé et tout à coup l'objet est à
nouveau là de l'autre côté de la voie
ferrée possédant des évolutions comme la
première fois avec des mouvements de
balancement des mouvements pendulaires
partent en revenant sarre et en
repartant et puis en définitive il est
parti tranquillement en direction de la
montagne légèrement à droite du puits du
louche à dire que vous apercevez là-bas
dans le lointain légèrement sur la
droite c'est à dire en pratique dans la
direction de clermont-ferrand
je dois dire un moment donné vers la fin
une voiture est passée comme celle ci
j'ai tenté d'attirer son attention en
vain la voiture a freiné en arrivant au
bout et nous avons entendu un homme qui
nous interpellait qui nous a dit qu'est
ce que c'est que cela avait vu ce gros
machin qui l'aurait dit derrière qui
étaient des pattes d'araignée des écrits
c'est moi d'abord se dégager comme du
gaz et des marchands de papier qui était
derrière et quel est le bruit que vous
avez entendu est ce que c'est un
sifflement ça comme un grincement excité
comme on dit un machin qui fait cette
claquette par c'est comme le du vent
dans les ordres oui moi je pense comme
moi j'ai entendu confiance qui a duré
combien de secondes pendant deux
poissons grands migrateurs écouter
charles le brun renflement dans les
oreilles j'étais tout ça vous fait
penser à quoi elle mais moi j'ai pas
grand chose penser après j'ai vu
monsieur rougerie me dis qu'est ce qu'on
pensait de sa vie moi je sais pas ce que
c'est moi je dis moi je peux pas
comprendre alors offert aux gens j'ai dû
moi je comprends pas non plus pas pu
comprendre que ça voulait venir
est ce à dire que les paluds moi je veux
vraiment j'étais en plein milieu savez
maintenant offrir aux gens là peut-être
la vision est plus près que moi moi j'ai
eu à peu près ça faisait mal et
promettre je trouvais à peu près ce que
vous pourriez décrire la forme à ces
messieurs je suis retenu pour décrire ça
commence à être pointés par a filmé puis
d'ennuyeux c'était gonflé un peu plus
par derrière je vous dis bien on aurait
dit qu'on me démaquille d'évaluer comme
ça se vit comme les tentacules oui
et pan dans l'évolution de la fin et en
attendant que vous ne le voyez plus en
dehors de ce sifflement du début avez
vous entendu un autre bruit à nous quand
on a plus aucun bruit
et vous avez-vous seul selon g
mais j'étais plus gros mais là au début
par il y en a qui doit tirer des petits
tout cas côté moi j'ai pas du tout et
vous vous avez des années après non
c'est vous qu'êtes vous non pas des
thons rouges en a bien quelques dizaines
à une désillusion dans le ciel mais pour
moi j'étais pas tout ça j'ai arrêté tout
seul j'aurais réunis mais comme j'étais
pas tout seul je voudrais vous demander
aussi quelle matière c'était les elle
semblait pas si vous avez observé une
libellule les ailes d'une libellule
grandi bédouine voit la ceni compath une
toile d'araignée parce qu'il ya quand
même de pizza qui planait dans le machin
là on sait pas ce que c'est
enfin c'est elle et elle ressemblait à
une toile d'araignée
oui comme un grillage leur aurait dit
moi je suis la structure la structure en
métal gris foncé qui ne brille pas et
tout le reste en grillage du monsieur
l'aise le corps même de l'engin ou
lesquels matière et moi je vous dis moi
j'ai dit à monsieur rochon là je dis on
aurait dit un machin d'araignée comme
les moins qu'une araignée une palme et
le corps même le corps même de de
l'objet est indéfinissable des
finisseurs ben
[Musique]